in a couple of weeks i'm heading to
oaxaca in mexico for my mom's birthday i
want to be extra safe as i travel so
before i go i'm planning on picking up a
few rapid covert 19 tests but i wanted
to know more about the science behind
how they work whether some tests on the
market are better than others and if
there's anything i can do to make sure
that i'm getting accurate results each
and every time so to help me and you
learn more about this i planned a little
testing expedition before my trip vamos
[Music]
there are a handful of rapid tests on
the market right now and more should be
coming we were on track to double the
supply of rapid home tests available in
the market each month by early november
and we are now on track to triple the
number by early november in theory you
should be able to walk into your local
pharmacy buy tests pretty easily and
then have results within 15 minutes in
mid-october i had to try a couple of
places before finding a few autumn i
decided to call my co-worker brianna
abbott because she's been covering kova
testing since the beginning of the
pandemic i wanted to know why coveted
rapid tests are so popular right now
part of it is delta the dynamics of the
delta variant actually arguably sort of
makes the test more useful in the summer
there was a surge in cases because of
the new variant causing demand for fast
acting tests to spike and some experts
say that the science behind the delta
variant makes these tests especially
valuable some data suggests that delta
may multiply more quickly inside the
body than previous variants so viral
loads peak faster making you contagious
sooner the more virus the easier it is
to detect some folks are calling these
contagiousness tests in part because
they're the best at figuring out whether
or not you have enough virus in your
system to sort of be infectious now we
don't know like the precise cutoff for
in infectiousness like as it relates to
how much virus you have in your system
but it tends to be that the more virus
you have the more infectious you are
identifying infections quickly and early
is even more critical for stemming the
spread of covid in the age of delta if
somebody's contagious now
you want to know if they're covered
positive now
not knowing if you were positive 24
hours ago or 48 hours ago that's gigi
granville she's a testing expert at the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health that lack time of 24 to 48 hours
she's referring to the time it usually
takes to get results back from pcr tests
sometimes it can take even longer which
isn't ideal in a pandemic that's pretty
much meaningless when it comes to public
health and infection control that lag
time has to do with how they work they
look for the virus as genetic material
to detect viral rna labs use special
machines that are kind of like a
molecular magnifying glass
these machines amplify genetic
information that takes time
they're so good they can pick up trace
amounts of genetic material even from
dead virus sometimes weeks after someone
has recovered but for rapid tests
there's no amplification step so if you
test positive that means that you have a
lot of virus in your nose at that time
and so a lot of people say that rapid
antigen tests are a really good measure
for if somebody is contagious because if
there's a lot of virus in somebody's
nose then that means that there's a lot
of virus in the air around somebody's
nose and could potentially be breathed
in by somebody else so how does it do
that let's unpack a kit
all the at-home rapid tests on the
market work pretty much the same way
they come with a little strip of paper
that is loaded with antibodies that
detect an antigen or viral protein
that's why these tests are called
antigen tests in this case that antigen
is the nucleocapsid protein which helps
the virus keep building new copies of
itself covet rapid tests also come with
a buffer solution that helps the sample
move from the swab to the antibody
carrying paper these tests are a little
bit like pregnancy tests same sort of
concept only with the pregnancy test you
bring your own liquid if you're negative
you'll only see one line if your swab
contains that nucleocapsid protein a
second line will appear on your test i
took my first rapid antigen test while i
was talking to gg no brain poke needed
open up the card first okay you'll see
two holes on the card one of those holes
is where you're going to stick the the
swab
and the other hole is where you're going
to drop the droplets open up the dropper
and you want to have six drops in that
uh that little hole okay here we go i'm
a little nervous not gonna lie so you
don't need to go too far
three quarters of an inch is what is
said in the instructions test
manufacturers found that there is enough
virus in the outer part of your nose
it's a lot easier to have a test when
you're not sticking a q-tip all the way
into the back of your head do five uh
counterclockwise or clockwise turns
five times
um so there are two holes do you see the
holes yeah
so you stick it into the first one
and then you see it and the second one
twist the swab
three times
and then there's a little adhesive yep
remove that and you close
the card
within 15 minutes i had my result it
appears that i am negative because you
only have that control line how would i
know if my test was inconclusive or what
i did something that like screwed it up
if you didn't see that line where it
says control then there was something
wrong with the test or something wrong
with what you did and that should be
tossed i asked gigi about how the
accuracy of rapid tests stacked up to
pcr because earlier in the pandemic
there were a lot of questions about how
well rapid tests worked and more
recently there's been recalls of certain
batches of tests she says the difference
between the accuracy of pcr and rapid
tests really depends on where you are in
the course of your infection she said
they matched up best when people have
symptoms which is usually when they have
the most virus and they're the most
contagious i didn't have any symptoms
when i took my test but gigi says that
more than how you feel it's important to
remember that these tests are only a
moment in time it's a matter of how much
virus is in your nose so it's just a
matter of getting enough information at
a frequent enough basis that you can
make some good decisions most at home
kits include two tests for that reason
according to the u.s food and drug
administration you're supposed to take
them a couple of days apart to up the
chances of detecting an infection in the
u.s frequent or serial testing can be an
issue not just because of availability
cost matters the test i took with gigi
which is made by avid laboratories cost
anywhere between 14 and 24 dollars for
two tests that starts adding up a little
bit too quickly for most people some
other readily available tests include
quick peel by quiddell which costs about
24-25 dollars for two tests and a loom
which runs about forty dollars for a
single test if you can't get them in a
store you can also order them on the
internet i ordered a two pack of the
access bio test online for fifty five
dollars including shipping that's one of
the more recently fda authorized tests
part of the push to have more tests
available so once you've actually
managed to take a test what can you do
with the results
gigi told me that my self-test should be
good enough to help me decide whether it
was okay to go see family and friends
but for international travel i need
certified results several companies are
now offering that service for rapid
tests including emed i ordered my test
online through their verified provider
that came at a premium i paid 70 dollars
for two of these tests that included the
telehealth appointment i had to book
with a certified health proctor the
company says it can't bill insurance
companies directly but that patients
should be able to get the costs
reimbursed do you see only a single pink
horse on the line next to the word
control at the top of the result window
yes all right you have tested negative
for coin 19 after i took my test my
results were available on an app and
emed also emailed them to me the data
also gets reported to public health
agencies we wanted to make sure that our
results are actionable that's patrice
harris she's the ceo and co-founder of
emed local state federal health
authorities could use our data and the
test results for their next steps be
that contact tracing the ability to
identify outbreaks experts say that's
one drawback of self-testing unless
you're taking a test like a loom or the
new beatty baritore test your test
results don't get automatically reported
to health authorities so the data kind
of gets lost that makes tracking
infections in your community tricky
having certified tests can help ensure
that the results are yours and that they
were taken within a certain time an
important consideration for travel so
after all that here's what i've learned
quantity matters how much virus there is
in your system how often you're testing
yourself and how much transmission there
is where you live the more cases the
more we should be testing on my first
try i got tripped up on how i was
supposed to insert the swab into the
card reader after that it was smooth
sealing if used correctly at home rapid
test can be an effective way to find
kovit because the immediacy of your
results can help us make more informed
decisions i felt better about having my
producer david over to my apartment to
make this video knowing i had just
tested negative for covid a rapid test
could also help doctors figure out who
to prescribe at-home covert treatments
to in the future the first at-home covet
treatment which we made another video
about could be available in the us by
the end of the year and in the longer
term some public health experts hope
that this foray into at-home testing
will spark a revolution in diagnostics
for infectious diseases more generally
the fluke would be up first because some
companies a lot of them were actually
working on tests that were supposed to
detect the flu and so the technology was
sort of in motion and then the pandemic
happened and some of these companies
pivoted and designed the tests around
equivalent instead sometime in the
future we could be swabbing our noses
for covid and other respiratory
illnesses that could make gathering in
crowds or going back to the office that
much safer we want to keep exploring how
science affects our daily lives so if
you have any suggestions for topics we
should tackle please leave them in the
comments and don't forget to hit
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
science and health updates hasta luego
nos vemos gracias
you